exigen el regreso del gobierno civil
jartúm capital de sudán volvió a ser
epicentro de protestas los manifestantes
bloquearon calles principales y quemaron
neumáticos frente al palacio
presidencial expresando su rechazo a la
actual régimen militar mientras que con
el ánimo de sofocar los disturbios las
fuerzas de seguridad descargaron gas
lacrimógeno sobre las multitudes siete
personas murieron y al menos 100
resultaron heridas según el comité
independiente de médicos de sudan
estoy en contra de la tiranía las
dictaduras o cualquier régimen que se
oponga a la libertad o la justicia de
las personas estoy en contra de la
desigualdad entre el pueblo sudanés ya
sea en la distribución de la fortuna la
libertad de expresión o cualquier otra
cosa
y
enfrentamientos de este tipo son
constantes desde el golpe de estado del
25 de octubre encabezado por el general
abdel fatah al burham los militares
restituyeron al primer ministro de la
anp doc después de liberarlo de su
prisión domiciliaria en un intento de
mantener la calma pero andoc renunció al
principio de este mes
estoy aquí para resistir el golpe
militar que tuvo lugar el 25 de octubre
esperamos que nuestra revolución libre
alcance la vía civil democrática y que
el pueblo sudanés logre todos sus
objetivos
actores civiles de oposición políticos y
militares han comenzado un proceso de
consultas liderado por naciones unidas
para poner fin a la crisis desatada por
el golpe que desde octubre ha cobrado la
vida de 63 civiles